In China, health officials confirmed at least 18 casualties...
...and over 600 cases of the coronavirus.
The government attempted to halt the virus' spread...
...by locking down three Chinese cities.
In Australia, a Canadian air tanker crashed while fighting bushfires in New South Wales,...
...killing all three American crew members on board.
Protesters in Lebanon threw stones and firecrackers...
...while police fired water cannons and tear gas canisters...
...in renewed protests against government corruption in Beirut.
A telecom billionaire ended a four-month strike...
...held by junior doctors at Zimbabwe state hospitals...
...by agreeing to pay the doctors a monthly allowance for six months.
Finally from Spain, police rescued 270 mistreated and sickly dogs...
...after raiding two illegal puppy farms in the outskirts of Madrid.